in the past a farmer would only be able
to milk a cow about twice a day now that
cows can sort of self-regulate their
milking hours they can do it three or
more times a day which is more
beneficial to the animal because if
they're not milked at the right time
it'll you know it'll back up it'll hurt
them
you know each count of the dairy farm
wears a unique Radio identification its
attributes can be looked up in a central
database so it'll keep track of the cows
size how active it is its weight how
much cut it's chewing so these machines
are kind of customized per cow so they
get to sort of understand the rhythms
the preferences of the cow so it's
almost like it's wearing a bovine Fitbit
it's important to keep things sanitary
so before the cows actually milked the
robotic systems wash off any
contaminants that might be on the other
floor and whether that's dirt or manure
but also it has kind of a nuzzling
effect so just that massaging action on
the udders releases a hormone called
oxytocin this is present in human
mothers as well it's kind of a bonding
chemical odd to think of a dirt brush
giving you the same rush of motherhood
but it also helps to stimulate milk so
our milk gets let down when she's ready
to be milked step 4 it's time for some
lasers and robots attach your teeth cups
to robot arms seal milk hose onto cups
attached vacuum hose affixed laser
guidance system to arm and insert steam
cleaner and antiseptic spray the
computer essentially knows like okay
it's Betsy
so she's about this high off the ground
and her four teats are kind of in this
arrangement once the robot has been
loaded with information about where the
cows teats are it has to position the
milking apparatus properly to do that it
uses a laser rangefinder it works by
emitting pulses of light and measuring
how long those pulses of light take to
reflect off an object my favorite part
about visiting a farm is looking at all
the droids and the laser beams measuring
the distance from one point tells us how
far the utter is from the milking arm by
measuring the distance from multiple
angles the computer can triangulate the
utters exact
the teeth cups have multiple actions
they use about 6 psi of vacuum pressure
which sucks out the milk and holds the
cups on inside each cup is a silicon
liner in pulsation chamber which
squeezes and releases the utter as the
vacuum turns on and off together they
mimic the sucking of a baby calf the
milking machine monitors the flow of
milk from the cow and when it notices
that the flow is dying down it
automatically disengages from the cow
it's utterly amazing